das unmögliche möglich gemacht die so
genannten geister teilchen die
eigentlich kaum zu fassen sind wurden
jetzt vermessen oder besser gewogen ein
deutsches forschungsteam vom karlsruher
institut für technologie konnte
neutrinos mit bislang unerreichter
genauigkeit vermessen somit ein neues
oberes limit für ihre masse bestimmen
und sie sind auf der spur eines weiteren
noch nicht nachgewiesene
elementarteilchen
klickst du uns einst im future geht es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen neutrinos die
geister teilchen des kosmos neutrinos
wiegend quasi nichts und seitdem
forschende das wissen haben sie nur ein
ziel dieses quasi zu messen die exakte
masse der neutrinos zu bestimmen ein
meilenstein ist jetzt den physikerinnen
und physikern vom karlsruher institut
für technologie gelungen ihre messungen
am sogenannten kathrin experiment kam
jetzt zu dem genauesten ergebnis
überhaupt mit der hilfe einer riesigen
tonnen schweren wagen und das ist nicht
irgendeine waage sondern die genaueste
waage der welt damit konnte jetzt
erstmals die grenze von einem
elektronenvolt ev durchbrochen werden
und das feiert die fachwelt als riesigen
erfolg zu welchem ergebnis sind die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
jetzt gekommen und wie kann man sich
diesen neutrino wagen karlsruhe
vorstellen was verraten die neuen
erkenntnisse über die natur der
mysteriösen geister teilchen die
antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen gibt es jetzt hier von mir bei
neutrinos handelt es sich um elektrisch
neutrale elementarteilchen die unter
anderem in der sonne oder beim
radioaktiven zerfall entstehen sie
gehören somit zu den häufigsten
elementarteilchen im universum und das
ganz unbemerkt von uns sie rasen fast
mit lichtgeschwindigkeit durch das alle
und hinterlassen dabei so gut wie keine
spuren nicht umsonst werden sie deswegen
auch als geister teilchen bezeichnet
dort trios interagieren nicht mit
gewöhnlicher materie sie rasen statt
dessen einfach durch sie durch durch
gebäude planeten menschen und sterne und
planeten schätzungen zufolge sind es pro
sekunde 60 bis 100 milliarden neutrinos
die auf jeden quadratzentimeter der erde
einprasseln lediglich spezielle neutrino
observatorien können diesen neutrino
beschuss beobachten dabei sind neutrinos
superwichtig von trinos formen galaxien
und stecken hinter der bewegung im
universum obwohl sie so häufig sind
gehören neutrinos zu den wohl
rätselhaftes teilchen unseres universums
viele fragen sind noch offen
möglicherweise spielen diese geister
teilchen eine entscheidende rolle für
viele kosmische phänomene die bislang
noch ungeklärt sind gemeint ist
beispielsweise die neue für sie jenseits
des standardmodells die unbekannten
teilchen der dunklen materie und das
mysteriöse ungleichgewicht zwischen
materie und antimaterie doch um all
diesen rätseln auf die schliche zu
kommen müssen physikerinnen und physiker
zunächst die frage nach der masse der
neutrinos klären denn dabei handelt es
sich trotz intensiver forschung um eine
bislang unbekannte größe doch um die
basics des universums endlich zu
verstehen muss die masse so exakt wie
möglich bestimmt werden dazu der us
kernphysiker heinz robertson wenn man
die masse der neutrinos müsste dann
würde man fundamentale fragen in der
kosmologie der astrophysik und der
teilchenphysik beantworten können warum
gibt es etwas und warum gibt es nicht
einfach nichts oder anders gefragt warum
ist beim urknall ein ungleichgewicht
zwischen materie und antimaterie
entstanden bis vor wenigen jahren war
man sogar davon ausgegangen dass
neutrinos gar keiner masse abend doch so
genannte neutrino oszillationen konnten
das gegenteil beweisen hierbei wandeln
sich die drei arten von neutrinos die
manchmal auch als flavour bezeichnet
werden ineinander um übersetzt heißt
kleber so viel wie geschmacksrichtung es
gibt die so genannten elektro neutrinos
sowie die taub und myon neutrinos vor
sieben jahren 2015 gab es für den
nachweis der neutrino oszillation und
damit auch den aller ersten hinweis auf
eine neue physik den nobelpreis für
physik seitdem steht also fest neutrinos
haben eine masse und das hat
auswirkungen auf das standardmodell der
teilchenphysik denn demnach müssten die
neutrinos eigentlich masse los sein
dieses modell stimmt also zumindest so
nicht bisherige messungen und
theoretische modelle grenzen die masse
der geister zeichen auf den bereich
zwischen 2 und 002 elektronenvolt ein
elektronenvolt ist die einheit für die
masse von elementarteilchen obwohl sie
normalerweise als einheit für energie
benutzt wird doch da laut der
einsteinschen relativitätstheorie masse
in energie umgewandelt werden kann ist
diese einheit auch für die masse möglich
doch wie überhaupt lässt sich ein
geister teilchen vermessen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
am karlsruher institut für technologie
kit haben dafür die weltgrößte waage für
neutrinos entwickelt im sogenannten
katrin experiment kommt es in einer 70
meter langen anlage zum beta zerfall von
radioaktivem tritium gas bereits vor
drei jahren 2009/10 hatten wir hier bei
klick substanzen future über den erfolg
in der ersten laufzeit des katrin
experiments berichtet damals gelang es
den physikerinnen und physikern die
masse des neutrinos auf maximal 1
elektronenvolt zu begrenzen doch die
anlage wurde seitdem gepumpt und nun
waren die messung mit einer noch höheren
präzision möglich doch wie genau
funktioniert diese riesige neutrino war
trieb sie um ein radioaktives
wasserstoffatom tritt in einem ersten
schritt in ein vakuum ohr bei seinem
zerfall wandelt sich ein neutron in ein
elektron ein proton und ein neutrino um
dann wird die bewegungsenergie des
elektrons gemessen daraus lässt sich
dann die energie des neutrinos und damit
auch seine masse ableiten doch dafür
müssen alle anderen elektronen
herausgefiltert werden dies geschieht
durch ein magnetfeld dass die teilchen
durch eine 23 meter lange vakuumkammer
führt nur die stärksten und schnellsten
die zusammen mit dem nackten neutrino
entstanden sind schaffen es bis auf die
andere seite zum detektor am ende des
versuchs heißt also im klartext dass
tatsächlich gar nicht die neutrinos
gemessen werden gemessen werden
stattdessen ihre begleiter die
elektronen und noch etwas konkreter das
experiment ist quasi den nackten
neutrinos auf der spur also den
neutrinos die bei beta zerfall nichts
von der freigesetzten energie abbekommen
haben denn damals weiß wie hoch die
ursprünglich freigesetzte energie war
kann man dann von der bewegungsenergie
des elektrons eine absolute masse
bestimmung der neutrinos vornehmen und
jetzt gibt es endlich die ergebnisse der
neuen messungen des katrin experiments
demnach muss die masse des elektron
neutrinos kleiner als 0,8 elektronenvolt
sein es hat also weniger als achtung ein
milliardstel der masse eines protons mit
dieser erkenntnis ist dem forschungsteam
von karate kid gelungen die neue
obergrenze der neutrino masse
festzulegen und diese unter den wert von
einem elektronenvolt zu senken dazu
heißt es in der aktuellen studie damit
haben wir nun eine von kosmologischen
modellen unabhängige information über
die neutrino masse an lehrer nun auch
nicht standardmodell der kosmologie
überprüft werden das jetzt noch
präzisere ergebnisse erlangt werden
konnten liegt daran dass die fachleute
in die signal rate erhöhen und
gleichzeitig die störsignale reduzieren
konnten diesen großen erfolg feiert die
fachwelt in der ganzen welt so
beispielsweise das fazit des us-models
pattonville kassen die teilchenphysik
gemeinschaft ist begeistert dass die
einst ev barriere von katrin
durchbrochen wurde doch damit gibt sich
das car kit noch nicht zufrieden die
präzision der neutrino waage soll noch
weiter erhöht werden die weiteren
messungen zur neutrino masse werden noch
bis ende 2024 andauern um das volle
potenzial dieses einzigartigen
experiment auszuschöpfen werden wir
nicht nur die statistik der signal
ereignisse kontinuierlich erhöhen wir
entwickeln und installieren fortwährend
verbesserung zur weiteren absenkung der
steuer ereignis rate und danach in drei
jahren 2025 soll noch ein neues detector
system tristan hinzukommen damit wollen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler vor allem die
sogenannten sterilen neutrinos dingfest
machen dabei handelt es sich um eine
bislang nur in der theorie
vorhergesagte vierter neutrino sorte
möglicherweise könnte es sich hierbei um
die teilchen der dunklen materie handeln
falls denn diese viertel neutrino sorgte
überhaupt existiert mysteriöse über
trinos kann jedes formel dieses rätsel
lösen in diesem video hier gibt es noch
mehr infos über die hintergründe der
neutrinos also anklicken und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran